good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast it's Friday Friday
gotta get down on Friday oh my God it's
Friday did you know that so exciting
it's so beautiful I love it you're not
dressed like it's a Friday well if I may
we have an unspoken rule here that
Friday is like merch sweatpant day it's
when you show up I may be like
snatched Karen from Finance it's not
nice thank you so much for that
compliment calling me snatch it's so
nice so he if I may can I understand can
I tell you my logic yeah of course all
week I dressed like it was Friday like
sweats merch just like really brought
nothing to the show and I've never loved
you more okay but this is my last show
for about 10 days yeah and I really
didn't want the last thumbnail to be
like me in a grout fit again I wanted to
leave them on a high note and so I just
felt like and also like for myself like
when I wear sweats that many days in a
row I'm like do my other clothes still
fit me so I just needed to like get into
some real clothes and I have a busy
weekend where I'm gonna be like dressing
up all weekend until I was like I might
as well get the ball rolling now and
like put on something with a zipper and
so here I am and also even though this
outfit like looks so fancy and fabulous
it's actually really comfortable sure
yeah so mine it's really comfortable I'm
wearing the toast
went to Spring and I and I shaved my
legs and put on a little self tanner so
I thought the Gams needed a day out the
Gams need a day out have you switched to
Isle of paradise yet no I haven't I used
San Tropez last night and it's pretty
good it makes me like a little like
green yellow yeah it's honestly it's not
the right fit for us I'm telling you I'm
not sure that it was but I also bought
like a spray bottle that's like kind
like that I have never used I bought it
I was influenced by an influencer and
she also has read her hair so I was like
okay maybe this will work for my
coloring too which one Sophia LA court
oh my God we're obsessed she's like a
tick where'd you buy it on it did you
follow her on Instagram I found her on
Instagram oh I only follow her on Tick
Tock yeah no I'm so thoroughly
influenced by her so I bought it but I
still never used it because every time
I've gone to use it I'm like what if I
do it wrong and then I have like a
wedding and so I need to use it like on
a boring week but yeah it hasn't
happened yet speaking of Sophia lacorte
what was that redheads book by Renee
carlino between two strangers Before We
Were Strangers Before We Were Strangers
and the main girl was a girl named Grace
who has red hair right I thought she had
blonde hair but sometimes those things
can translate differently for people
well whatever I imagined when I was
reading the book and I was very like
into it the whole time I thought of the
main girl Grace as Sophia lacouri
because I like just started seeing her
on Tick Tock and she was like in my
brain and now I just have like
association between the two that's
really funny yeah
um I just want to tell you really
quickly about my night because I just
did like so many things you know I went
to Comedy Cellar which was so premium
like you know usually you go see a
comedy show like some comedians are
better than others like this was just
like sickening lineup and I guess that's
like the point of Comedy seller it's
like a premium
every single comic was better than the
next like it was so hysterical like I
was actually like belly laughing and it
was first of all they take your phones
when you end like your Apple watches
when you walk in
so at first I was like a little annoyed
like crazy anxiety I was like oh man
what if I get canceled like I just like
something about not being on my phone
just gives me terrible anxiety but once
I was able to let that go it was so
premium for a million reasons like you
know we operate very much in the digital
space which is this like you know
sensitive
politically correct
safe space
um at least our corner of it and just to
hear people like making crazy [ __ ]
jokes like about everything was so
refreshing I forgot that people talk
that way like because we like we just
don't joke like that and it was so
refreshing and I was just like cackling
the whole time and it was like a whole
it like refreshed my brain that like you
can joke about stuff and it was so
delightful and I loved the premise of no
one having their phones like it was just
really
safe like for the comics and it was just
so premium and I just I can't recommend
going to Comedy seller enough like and I
guess Cena goes like all the time okay
gotta go a lot and it's so premium like
I have been a million years ago because
it's by NYU and they had like a really
small club and now they have like
multiple locations and I went to like
one of the big ones with like air
conditioning and it was like so premium
and like it had like a million drinks
mozzarella sticks like really premium
can't recommend if you're looking for
something fun to do in New York premium
I hadn't heard you know I think we're
thankful for your recommendations like
been knowing this also a lot of times
Like Comics will well-known like A-list
Comics show up there to try out new
material like Amy Schumer's always
spotted so Dana literally waked outside
comedy comedy seller every night until
she can go and see Amy Schumer and she's
actually gotten to see her yeah I mean I
guess the point most people go of course
for the show but like hoping that a
celebrity is just gonna like stop by and
I was like really hoping like Dave
Chappelle or like when they took our
phones I was like do they do this every
night or is someone special coming and
Pete Davidson is like very strict about
phones at his show so I was the whole
time I was waiting for Pete Davidson who
never showed up but the show was so good
like I actually did not mind yeah
premium experience so I know everyone
knows that but I just never go downtown
like that's nice that you know it now
yeah it was so fabulous like I want to
go again you should and the air
conditioning like I just can't stress
how high powered and voluminous it was
that's amazing and then I like had a
night on the town and I really am proud
of myself because it's a Friday and I'm
not hungover like you know it's a Friday
we saw your stories last night I was
like okay karate's going out and she's
going out again and more and more and I
was like okay so it's a hungover show
and I'm wearing a [ __ ] bow it is what
it is yeah
um but look at you no first of all I got
home at like 12 because comedy seller
was like eight to ten and then we had
dinner and drinks from like 10 to 11 30.
and it was just like a civilized adult
night like not I guess I'm realizing
this now like not every night has to be
like blacked out until the break of dawn
sounds like last night was the night of
realizing stuff for you it was because I
still had fun and I was so happy to be
home by 12 like yeah and like to go to
sleep without the spins without the
spins and I woke up feeling completely
fine that is so Claudia that's beautiful
I would love to eventually get to a
place where my partying and my work life
can sustain each other again there's no
reason why they should constantly be in
Conflict they're constantly battling one
another and it's so toxic for my mental
health well I'm glad that there was a
date hunt last night and that you can
give us State Hunt is like peace
ceasefire God yeah there was a ceasefire
for sure and then you can give us full
Claudia today yeah no I'm thrilled to be
alive on a Friday it's nice it's
beautiful these Friday weekends ahead of
you yeah beautiful stuff I have such a
busy weekend like I said so
we're here we got to do what we got to
do we gotta do what we gotta do and
other I actually had a really busy day
yesterday like all the errands I've been
putting off like manicure pedicure like
Wax Etc so I was just Aaron's Aaron's
errands meetings meetings meetings
podcast podcast so we're gonna do what
we do best and we're gonna podcast for
you on this stunning so hot Friday even
though I'm still wearing a sweatshirt
don't ask me why
um I'm still cold in the studio not as
cold as it's been it's as if someone
here watches our show and saw us
struggling well if you're watching the
show we don't agree on the air
conditioning thing please this is the
perfect air conditioning back on work
this is a perfect temperature you can
wear shorts and they're not needing a
blanket it's a little hot perfect
temperature it's just yeah okay and your
ringside Church yeah yeah yeah a
form-fitting sweatshirt so that never
helps yeah
um so let's dive in because we've got a
we don't have a lot to talk about
because like we said um well we actually
didn't say we said it before the show
there's true slim pickings tell us about
your experience trying to choose today
was one of those days where I went
through all the sites and I was still at
zero stories wow so I had to go through
them all again and I had to go to like
the reserve sites and you know what you
are going to get some interesting world
news but I know you guys would love to
hear it especially on Friday when you're
going out to embark on a weekend you
might need meet new people maybe you
guys need to talk about Jeff Bezos going
to space maybe you need some interesting
factoids about it maybe like maybe
you're gonna be at a wedding and you're
gonna be like you know a far-off friend
who gets seated at a table with people
you don't meet you don't know you've
never met and you need something talk to
talk about and you'll be so grateful you
listen to this random ass episode of the
toast right and you're gonna be like
what do you think about shark attacks
and right now that doesn't mean anything
to you but in 45 minutes you're gonna
have a whole new opinion on that yeah
and you know what after coming from
Comedy seller I have this whole new Vibe
like I'm ready to offend people and I
think the shark Community is going to be
my first Target because they've been
inspired by the brave comedians who
fought for our right to joke about
whatever we want to joke about and I'm
feeling all revved up like I want to be
like a crazy offensive comedian today
okay cool that's exciting for all [ __ ]
you all and your pitbulls
she can't handle it I can't I was 100
kidding like please don't come for me
okay cool now I think without further
Ado where are you right here being
perfect it is time for the past five
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast
and I'll give you one guess as to who
today's sponsor is
[Music]
is the best electric toothbrush on the
market the official unofficial morning
toast official toothbrush if you haven't
gotten one yet you're probably the last
listener of this podcast who hasn't
gotten one upgrade your tooth brushing
experience with an electric toothbrush
that is so affordable you know what some
electric toothbrushes can cost over 200
which is insane but the brush is
Affordable and it's truly the best one
out there my dentist even said so so the
brush itself comes with six unique modes
to customize your brushing experience
the battery life lasts four weeks and it
comes with a magnetic charging stand and
a compact travel case they also offer a
subscription program so you never forget
to switch out your brush head they'll
ship you new replacement heads every six
months so you're never stuck using a
worn down brush head there is their
Sleek design has a modern aesthetically
pleasing design that comes in Trend
driven seasonal colors and it looks
great on your bathroom counter they just
came out with some sickening Anna
Wintour approved colors that will just
really elevate your home Morning
Experience mornings are hard Bruce makes
it easy get 15 off your brush toothbrush
kit and the refill plan when you use
promo code toast brush.com that's 15 off
using promo code toast at
bruush.com jump on this because if
you've been wanting to get a toothbrush
um that's electric and you don't want to
spend a lot of money that's a it's
sizable savings 15 off code toast at
bruce.com it's electric
okay first story you know we'll hit you
with some mindless celeb news Machine
Gun Kelly had a Megan Fox poster in his
bedroom as a teen oh that's cute isn't
that cute the rapper now 31 had a poster
of FOX NOW 35 hanging in his bedroom as
a teenager years before the pair ended
up dating he said it was from her GQ
shoot so that's some full circle [ __ ] as
now they are very much in love and
together yeah I guess that's so crazy
that's kind of like how well they're not
dating but like Billy eilish is like a
comrade of Justin Bieber when like her
whole Early Childhood was devoted to
stanning Justin Bieber yeah you love to
see people living out their dreams to me
it reminds me of the story of Jason
Momoa and Lisa Benet
when he saw her on TV and he said and he
literally pointed to her on the TV and
he said
turn to his mom and he pointed to Lisa
on the television was like Mama
I'm gonna marry her which is kind of
weird just
how old was Lisa she was on a Cosby Show
right yeah and she's older than him
right now of course so like I just want
to know how old he was when he was
fantasizing you know it's just like age
is so weird you know yeah it is weird
when you think of things in those terms
but it could also be cute and in this
situation I think it's cute if you ever
heard Jason Momoa tell the story about
like him looking at the TV Google it
it's so funny because all I took away
from it was mama
and if you've been listening to the show
long enough yeah you know that's a
morning breath joke you know that that
sent us I just want to like I'm so
confused on who our audience is actually
because we we have so many toasters who
are new we have so many OG toasters who
fall off the wagon like who are The
Toasters right now do you guys know that
Mama joke because I can start recycling
jokes making them like they're new you
know right no first of all the toast is
a revolving door literally and I I do
feel like so many listeners have been
with us since day one but I don't want
to exclude those new ones but I also
think that so many are constantly
discovering us because we'll get
comments like what's RDH like that's not
even that old so yeah you know I think
that this is really for everyone it's
ubiquitous so if you're an OG toaster
apologies for the redundancy I just
think that's a really good inside joke
we need to bring back yeah I agree we
use so many inside jokes so many Justice
for the girls I know apparently someone
reminded us that's what we used to wish
for at 11 11. right just for the girls
in reference specifically Kelly Justice
for those girls Justice for like all the
girls just is for girls everywhere
agreed okay so he had a picture uh who
are we talking about oh Machine Gun
Kelly yeah yeah I feel like that
actually tracks just like timeline wise
I feel like every guy who like grew up
in the 90s or early 2000s had a big ass
poster of like Megan Fox because she was
the the the it gal the 2000s yeah what
did I say 90s yeah two thousands I feel
like I've been in bedrooms like where
there was a Megan Fox poster yeah for
sure she's definitely like a poster girl
what post did you have oh you had a
Backstreet Boys post I did it was very
cool and like it was like not even a
poster it was like a silk it was like a
silky material like it wasn't like
something that you wear from magazine it
was like it was gifted to me where it
like rolled down it was yeah it's like a
parchment honestly like a piece of art
yeah Olivia had the same one for insane
and if you want to hear about the
Australia family childhood battle
between insync and Backstreet Boys which
is a lot more fascinating than you might
think read about it in my New York Times
bestselling book a girl with no job the
crazy beautiful life of an Instagram
thirst monster yeah so that Jackie O
approved she read it four times
three
sorry I just because I said this week I
brought it three times that like people
would like so you haven't read it one
more time since we last spoke it's
disgusting I haven't had a medal I'm
sorry
are you ready for our next story which
is some cute exciting news some CES yeah
yeah Kyle Richards will be starring in a
movie for Peacock called The Real
Housewives of the North Pole oh I didn't
know that that's what it was called I
just read the headline that she was
doing like a Hallmark holiday movie and
I'm like oh cute perfect for like her
level of acting called The Real
Housewives of the North Pole which is
actually like even more perfect but a
little confusing yeah because now I'm
not thinking it's gonna be like a you
know
a Hallmark holiday movie it's going to
be like a parody no well I no I don't
think it's going to be a parody I think
it's going to be a Hallmark holiday
movie about I don't know and who are the
other Housewives cast as the only other
cast member announces Betsy Brandt yes I
saw that on Kyle's Instagram and I do
not know who she is me neither but
peacock announced on Thursday that an
original film titled The Real Housewives
of the North Pole will arrive on the
streaming service later this year Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills that Kyle
Richards will star in the project
alongside Breaking Bad Alum Betsy brand
hoochie play in Breaking Bad do you
recognize this woman
kind of Breaking Bad was so long ago no
honestly I've literally never met that
woman in my life okay well you're about
can you yeah can you tell me who she
played sure
Marie oh yeah yeah yeah yeah the DEA
agent's husband yeah yeah oh my God she
was so annoying well you never watched
Breaking Bad I know I thought about this
we have spoken about it and it's
honestly not even on my content plate I
have a really kind of hot take for you
when it comes to peacock in you know the
wars of streaming peacock is like
[ __ ] the bed like they're not doing
anything even remotely remarkable except
for the Real Housewives All-Stars which
hasn't even come out yet and I just feel
like every time we hear something like
that they're doing I'm just not into it
and also I have every streaming service
I don't even know if I have peacock
downloaded on my Apple TV and if I do I
never open it except one time when I was
with Olivia we watched at her house we
watched NYC prep that was premium they
have a pretty good cat backlog catalog
Bethany Ever After and when I did watch
Downton Abbey I'm pretty sure it was on
peacock even though it is now on Netflix
definitely check it out here's a little
more by the way all the as of like last
week all of the Twilight films are now
on Netflix and I bought them on Amazon
Prime so like it doesn't really affect
me happy to support the franchise though
it's so exciting and you know if it's
reaching new people that's just so
beautiful for like we're always
welcoming new what Stan here's a little
descriptor of the movie in the upcoming
film Richards and bran Stars Trish and
Diana aka the Christmas Queens of North
Pole Vermont okay so they're not like
Santa's elves okay okay that's important
to clarify it is the Christmas Queens of
North Pole Vermont Trish and Diana have
won the best holiday house decorating
competition every year for the past nine
years this sounds so good but days
before Christmas a friendship-ending
argument Sparks a town-wide feud and
draws the attention of a national
magazine writer hoping to make a name
for herself with her scintillating
expose titled Real Housewives of the
North Pole okay this sounds
stunning stunning oscar-worthy so they
obviously have like a battle they both
will decorate their home separately
Tribeca Film Festival is Sundance can
Toronto Tiff they're all calling saying
we want this film it sounds so good
Dennis okay I take back maybe maybe
peacock is on to something maybe peacock
is onto something I mean you really
can't go wrong with um a great Christmas
movie premise and then to have this like
Housewives tie-in makes it uniquely
peacock uniquely people no one else
could unique lock
no one else could no one else could this
actually does not sound bad it does not
sound bad I'm excited for Kyle I haven't
really seen Kyle act in anything
except on this week's Real Housewives of
Beverly Hills when they did the
flashback to Little House on the Prairie
I'm not gonna lie I was quaking yeah I
was shook yeah my bed was just rocking
yeah so was hers literally because she
had scarlet fever so upsetting um so I
don't think I've ever seen her act in
anything so
she wasn't acting an American woman
right she was produced she was producing
and I never saw her remake to Witch
Mountain or no that was when she was
still a kid yeah she also did that in um
what's that scary movie that's like
really famous that she's in with Mike
Myers and um Jamie Lee Curtis
Halloween they redid it too never saw it
either so okay so this will be the first
I'm definitely gonna watch us and you
know what I'm not trying to like jump to
any conclusions or anything but we are
like low-key like really close to
Christmas I know you know I was when I
was watching Potomac it made me so
excited for winter when they were
pulling up to um when they were like
getting out of the car and it was like
snowy and icy and like it was like
chilly I was like I love that feeling no
I know and honestly like I'm on this
side of tick tock where it's like they
show you Christmas cookie videos and
it's like 105 days till Christmas and
honestly I feel like a part of growing
up is like a really I feel like when you
were a kid you would like die for the
summer and now I'm like The Summer's so
[ __ ] hot myself to work like I want
Christmas time like once Halloween
starts like I feel like I'm actually the
happiest and that really Hearts back to
what I said yesterday about my me having
reverse seasonal depression like the
Summers does not make me happy nice
weather does not make me happy like
staying inside with a hot cocoa and a
fire roaring and a Christmas tree like
that really brings me joy you would
cultivate Vibes there are no Vibes
cultivated in the summer so funny yes
because literally like I just made the
decision to sit in my living room on
Sunday and my check cultivated Vibe like
light some candles down the lights
doesn't work it's too hot to like
candles it doesn't work in the summer it
doesn't work so I just feel like
normalized
standing winter I think a lot of people
do the only thing I'll say is like yes
that time is so exciting Halloween my
birthday Christmas like everyone's
quaking we're so lucky to have a
birthday in November but then after New
Year's it is a leak
dark for a while but for like four
months but you know what I've realized
since then
and I feel like when I was younger I
used to get like really depressed after
winter break and it's like so much time
until next summer or winter or summer
break
but you know what's the cool thing about
like the years is that they always come
back around so it's like yes okay you
could say it's you know
right after Christmas but you could also
say 360 days till Christmas you know
what I mean I I understand what you're
what you're saying but I just no
whatever the message I'm trying to
instead we should plan like an amazing
trip for like
February March have something to look
forward to you know you're 100 right
February and March are really dark yeah
we need a I mean I guess we have like
Passover slash Easter in like April yeah
but no and Valentine's Day in February
but that's like a fake [ __ ] holiday
yeah but no
yeah no need to check yeah let's get on
that let's get on that yeah we're gonna
preempt the calendar yeah all right
ready for our next story yeah Mark
Wahlberg regrets going on an 11 000
calorie diet to quickly gain weight for
his new movie
you know I really actually enjoy
reporting on stories where like method
actors or like really like highly
trained actors get into shape or like
gain weight lose weight for a movie
because the fact that people can have
that much control over their weight is
the most impressive thing to me like if
I knew how to do that I could literally
build a rocket like I would be the
smartest person ever the 50 year old
departed starvis The Tonight Show on
July 15th to promote his forthcoming
drama Joe Bell during the interview
Jimmy Fallon asked about the recent
shoot for his latest films too during
which Mark at one point gained at least
20 pounds over the course of three weeks
to portray a real-life boxer-turned
priest when he spoke with Jimmy I mean
back in April before the process had
begun Mark sounded excited ebulent about
the chance to gain a significant amount
of weight over the course of the 30-day
film shoot however as he explained to
Jimmy Fallon he has since learned this
was perhaps not the wisest Choice he
said unfortunately I had to consume for
two weeks seven thousand calories and
then for another two weeks eleven
thousand calories and it was fun for
about an hour it was such a hard
physical thing to do losing weight you
just kind of tough it out you just don't
eat and exercise and this even when
you're full I would wake up after a meal
and have another meal I was eating every
three hours it was not fun I really just
like I've never related lessons like
Wahlberg yeah no I can I can understand
the um the plight of like having to eat
when you're not hungry that's actually
painful but to even compare it to being
harder than losing weight like no well I
also think maybe like mentally when you
are like grinding to lose weight there's
like you know you have a goal in your
and you want to work towards that goal
but like the goal on this end is just to
you know be unhealthy and it's like hard
to motivate yourself to want to do that
to your body yeah I guess that's true
but like especially when you're someone
like Malcolm
Mark Wahlberg who's like always up in
the gym working on his Fitness he's my
witness yeah right he'd be right him
down the block just to watch what I got
so delicious so delicious but you know
what Mark Wahlberg like is Fergalicious
so I feel like that's that makes this
whole thing okay yeah no he's definitely
Fergalicious but I he was struggling
with things that were delicious
and his witness
and he'd be riding around the block just
to watch what I got to
Fergalicious death
Fergalicious definition
when you don't want to like yeah but
like imagine just like oh I wish my life
was involved with like me having to gain
weight to make like 30 million dollars
in a movie like I'm sorry these
celebrities are getting more and more
out of touch okay probably but it's like
Jimmy Fallon asked you know yeah and
that's on Jimmy found out like they go
on these shows to talk about what
they've been up to and like that's what
he's been up to yeah I do feel like I
haven't really heard a lot about Jimmy
Fallon you know what I mean I feel like
he was like interfaces for a while I
feel like I go out of my way not to hear
about Jimmy Fallon like I saw an a
headline about move away like yeah you
have like I said on the jimmies like I
[ __ ] can't if you had to rank the
jimmies to me they're both really bad I
would say including James Gordon James
Gordon is probably my favorite because
of like carpool karaoke and he's given
us a lot I would say the little Jimmy
Kimmel no Fallon the shorter one it's
smaller how many jimmies are there Jimmy
Jimmy Jimmy Kimmel no I think Jimmy
Kimmel is like you don't know you're
Jimmy Kimmel is the bigger one
no
yeah there Jimmy Fallon is taller okay
Jimmy Kimmel is not the one I'm talking
is is the bigger one wait and so which
Jimmy is there another gym Jimmy Fallon
yeah Andy's friend I was gonna say
that's the smaller one I would argue
he's bigger he's taller wait
okay Jimmy Fallon height oh six foot
okay I guess that's pretty tall let's
find Jimmy Kimmel's height well I think
he's like five nine
Jimmy Kimmel height
six one so I was right no he's not two
it's literally what does it say six one
Joe Joe Kimmel is not six one but on a
different side it says five foot eleven
you just can't get straight answers okay
whatever so if you had to rank best to
worst okay I I really don't like them
all I would say I like Fallon more than
Kimmel if of course if I had to say yeah
and you like James Corden better than
both of them yes but also because like I
guess James Corden is around a lot and
like in your face or the Gen Z
generation
hates Jimmy Fallon like no [ __ ] James
Corden really yes they despise him like
they were there was so much outrage that
he was um
on the Friends reunion like they just
think he's so annoying and honestly I
like him you do like him yeah
I just lost all my stories like
trying to find the jimmies okay and
that's why I [ __ ] hate the jimmies
take your time because our search for
the stories is brought to you by Athena
Club oh wait no I think I found them
well I'm in the middle of something
guys when we were holed up at home it
was okay to not shave your legs but it's
time to get friendly with our razors
again for us summertime means shaving
more often and there's no better razor
than the Athena Club razor shaving used
to be something we dreaded but Athena
club's products make it more fun and
easier to shave not only is it the
prettiest razor we've ever seen but it's
also gentle on our skin leaving it
moisturized super smooth and most
importantly bump free so true there's a
visible difference in the shape for me
it's super close no razor bumps smells
great all of their products it's a
really premium experience and you know
what I feel like a part of growing up is
like investing in your razor not just
like using some [ __ ] you find
at the bottom of your like kitchen set
and the one that you've been using for a
year that has rust on it so the Athena
Club razor is designed with built-in
skin guards to help prevent razor burn
while being gentle on your curves the
razor blade is surrounded by water
activated Serum with shea butter and
hyaluronic acid which is the Holy Grail
for skin care the best part is that the
razor kit is only nine dollars it comes
with two blade heads a magnetic hook for
shower storage and your choice of handle
color also the magnetic Hook is a true
Game Changer the razor has cute color
handle options they also have black and
white razors for all of you minimalists
plus you never have to worry about
running out of refills or being stuck
with dull overused razors because you
can choose how often your replacement
blades ship to you for free and that
means fresh ready to use razors always
arrive right when you need them they
have the devious dreamiest shave foam
which is my favorite product from Athena
club that will leave your skin soft
hydrated and smooth another part of
growing up it's like you know throwing
some soap on your legs and shaving them
it's not going to cut it like use
premium products Athena Club has you
covered show your skin some care with
the Athena Club razor kit sign up to
chain you'll get 20 off your first order
just go to athenaclub.com use the promo
code toast that's a t h e n a club.com
with promo code toast for twenty percent
off off Athena club.com Athena club.com
promo code toast for 20 off thank you
for that Claudia you're unbelievable my
stories are back okay good why I got
them I
I they didn't just pop that boys are
back the boys are back probably the
worst song from High School Musical but
the most that were there in the junkyard
yeah atrocious and then they're like
kids oh my God so bad horrible
anyways in a little space news of the
week you guys know Jeff Bezos is going
to space and his flight will include the
youngest and the oldest humans to go to
space I just feel like he's
overcompensating for the fact that
Richard Branson got there first he's
like well I'm gonna break some World
Records like 100 and I can understand
why like you know he made all these
strides to go to space and he's not even
going to be like the first billionaire
private like bought a ticket to go to
space no now you're like a loser copier
so I understand his need to like one up
and do something for the Guinness Book
of World Records sure but I don't think
that this is it no it's not even
impressive not not to be rude like could
he bring a dog to space love that idea
you know also like he's just giving me
like major Luanda steps like early Real
Housewives of New York Vibes like
constantly went up being like her fancy
friends this is just like I feel like
you should just take the loss you know
like him overcompensating for getting
their second with these losery attempts
it's kind of making the whole thing more
losery and it's like if you really want
to go to space like that should be
enough for you like do it for
don't do it for other people so like if
that doesn't fulfill you going to space
on its own whether your first second
third but by the way your second don't
think that you're first don't get it
twisted then like really what's the
point of how much money you spend and
all of this no you're sorry that's
actually one of the key takeaways from
my best-selling book girl with no job
the crazy beautiful life of an Instagram
third sponsor it's like doing things for
yourself not for like the perception of
others and I feel like that's something
Jeff Bezos could actually really use
from my book yeah get it on Amazon
really easily Prime comes in a day yeah
I'm sure or the Kindle is awesome like
in a minute yeah oh he could download it
on his Kindle on his way to space great
read you know for his journey yeah space
read right it's like you could take a
book into there's so many things that
you could do you know you're 100 right
if we're gonna break a record like let's
do a cool one this is honestly not
inspiring at all but he's taking an 18
year old and an 82 year old and that's
what he wants you to know and that's
what he thinks is gonna set him apart I
just have to say and I don't want to
jinx anything I'm not trying to be like
a bad Omen but like all this like
billionaire like having fun in space
spending money it's all fun and games
till something goes wrong you know like
we're we're not just like you know
taking a roller coaster ride like we're
actually doing something incredibly
dangerous 100 which reminds me of
Jessica Simpson's book which is when
like she was in school and they were
watching they were watching the space
take off I forget what the name of the
flight was we weren't we weren't alive
the one that crashed and like they
played it in all the schools it was like
such a big deal the Challenger seven
years old
and they never took off the whole thing
just exploded no they took off and and
it exploded okay so and they all like
were watching it yeah like all these
kids were traumatized a generation of
kids traumatized from watching like a
live
killing yeah so I'm just saying like
we're all just joking about it but it's
actually very dangerous and NASA even
the world's leading space researchers
even though you hadn't made a mistake a
couple years ago with the Challenger so
like it's not that crazy but it's a
dangerous job I think that's what Jeff
wants you to to think too like Jeff
Bezos Brave I'm not gonna lie when I
think of Jeff Bezos a lot of adjectives
come up and brave is not on that list I
think of smart
grade 8 uh bald like I think of a lot of
things Brave no I think of newspaper in
the morning that's what I think I think
of I want to get drunk with you not not
too drunk just a little tip say yeah
that's what I think and I want to read
the newspaper with you so sick that's
really what I think of honestly I hope
he brings a newspaper to space to be
honest
I really don't think Jeff Bezos has ever
fully recovered reputation-wise from his
skin text messages here's what's crazy I
think that he has recovered
reputation-wise
a hundred percent like nobody even
references it anymore like he's still
with her even though it's like the
brother who leaked the messages but for
me like that's all I think about and
it's I guess because he like decides
what people think about he's put it out
of their minds and so even if I like
can't be like controlled that can't be
tamed yeah like that I'm still thinking
about it but I can't say a really good
point I can't believe that everybody's
moved on in the way that they haven't
not every article starts with Jeff Bezos
who once said I want to wake up with you
and read the newspaper like no by the
way you're 100 right but I can believe
that people have forgotten about it for
the exact reason you just mentioned like
he owns the Washington Post he's like
one of the most
powerful people in our country like of
course we're no longer thinking about it
he doesn't want us to
put a chip in us like you're 100 right
so that's my that's my thoughts but I
we're at the morning toes we're here to
remind you like those things happen you
know what you know what I think I'll do
today I think I'll repost those text
messages
hashtag never forget and probably my
favorite time to ever be alive was when
his text messages came out and there was
like a challenge in the toaster
Community when girls were sending word
for word what he was like these creepy
kind of like lame attempts at romance
yeah romantic text messages to their
like fiances or girlfriends or husbands
and the responses we're so funny that
was like my favorite time to be alive
yeah and now I have nothing to live for
because everyone's forgotten everyone's
forgotten but not us you can't you can't
run away from it Jeff like you can go to
space but we'll never forget just like
how
who did you say you said Jason Momoa was
Zoe
no remember release it remember when you
said that Jason Momoa
that that Zoe Kravitz is Jason momoa's
stepdaughter yeah yeah daughter what's
wrong with me
yeah remember when you said that and
like now it's like I don't know where I
was going with this maybe just went on
okay I'll move on until you can get your
footing back it's not gonna happen so
are you ready for our fifth and final
story only if it's the final story
[Music]
we need a triangle because when I when I
hit yes when I hit that last note I just
want to ding the truck order it from
Jeff bezos's blog
okay our fifth and final and we'll get
like a little hook and we'll hang it
right yeah it's just like or maybe we
need like a what's it called on the
drums a Timber timble no no but for this
particular song The Sound we're
emulating is a triangle I actually feel
like what's it called
like I think that is actually more of
the vibe I'm personally going for
musically okay that's fine for you but I
want a triangle can you order two
triangles
thanks that's exciting you guys the
toast is moving on up we're becoming a
musical show we always were yeah but we
used to be acapella and now we're gonna
have instruments yeah we're going
acoustic
are you ready God my legs are hairy I
really need to use my Athena Club razor
are you ready for our fifth and final
story can you guys see it no they can't
because my legs have been so hairy all
week this is actually like hutzpah level
no they can't see it I've already
conducted this experiment on the show
can you see it your my hair from your
purview no okay no I don't think so
are you ready yeah perfect and final
story because it's so controversial
shark Advocates are calling for a
rebranding of violent attacks as
interactions so they want them to be
called instead of shark attacks they
want them to be called Shark
interactions Marine experts and
advocates in Australia are urging the
public to refrain from using the word
attack in reference to sharks declaring
that the Majestic predatory fish has
been unfairly stigmatized as a
deliberate killer instead officials have
suggested that violent run-ins with
sharks be dubbed with more neutral words
such as interactions others have
suggested swapping the word with the
terms negative encounter incident or
simply bites
the University of Sydney language
researcher Christopher pepiness said
shark attack is a lie he argued that a
majority of what people call attacks are
merely nips and minor injuries from
smaller sharks
like honestly
stories like this make me not want to
like live in this world anymore like for
real like are you [ __ ] serious like
you're worried about the shark's
feelings like no offense shark says
watch the news no and like no events
like sharks on her feelings and they
don't really care about like your sharks
don't speak English okay
don't speak English totally and like I
just can't believe that they're like
actually really smart people who have
dedicated their entire lives to like
Professor to Academia and and this is
what they came up with like no wonder we
haven't cured cancer yet everyone's
focused on the dumbest [ __ ] of all time
like the Linguistics of sharkhood like I
I honestly can and
it's really upsetting like I know we're
joking but like it's really upsetting no
do you know what I'm saying this is
really upsetting because this is what
we've gotten to as a society minutia of
how we refer to shark attacks and I'm
sorry we don't attack sharks they attack
us it's an attack
it's an attack
so I'm just like disgusted like I really
am
especially coming off of being a comedy
seller last name where like everyone was
saying the craziest [ __ ] and I'm like
really and now I'm back in the real
world like where it's like interactions
it's a shark interaction literally like
how did we get here like I was so upset
and it also like it you worry about okay
say you know what shark enthusiasts go
ahead like then what's next no of course
it's not about the Sharks even though it
kind of is like it's just about it's not
about the Sharks honestly it's about the
people because the Sharks don't care no
and it's like if only the Sharks knew
that like there were these losers
advocating
literally and you know what Justice for
anyone who's ever been bitten by a shark
this is so insensitive to them yeah and
I'm just really sick and I reject this I
reject I reject no shark attack attack
attack attack attack attack attack
attack attack attack attack attack shark
attack shark attack shark attack shark
attack shark attack what are you gonna
do what are you gonna do shark attack
shark attack shark attack
what was that oh it was a shark attack
attack what are you gonna do about that
huh Professor Christopher what do you do
attack
shark attack
hmm
Christopher
you're reminding me of that shark from
Finding Nemo
you know the one fish are friends not
food yeah um and I feel like honestly
that movie was actually detrimental and
was one of the reasons that got us here
it's like look the shark is nice it's
not based on a real story no shark ever
said Fisher friend not food because they
eat fish because they don't speak
English that as well so I just feel like
it's kind of been this like
subliminal messaging teaching our kids
like normalizing normalizing trucks and
it's like they are a deadly predator no
Ellen animated feature film is gonna
change that right shark attack shark
attack and honestly like you can't
negotiate with the shark no you can't
and I wouldn't suggest it and also and I
just really can't stress this enough as
you said so poignantly poignantly
sharks don't speak English also like
when I said like what comes next I'll
tell you what it would be they would
make them change the name of Shark Tank
no doubt they would make them change the
name because it's offensive to sharks
I'm surprised we haven't gotten there
yet in this Twisted Society but if this
if this goes through that's what's next
it's not gonna go through you want to
know why because we reject it yeah shark
attack shark attack shark attack attack
we need Kevin O'Leary back on the show
just to discuss this 100 so anyways if
you do find yourself like at a dinner
party or a wedding this weekend like I
do feel like this is a good topic of
conversation you can get to know a lot
about someone based on what they what
their opinion is their story 100 and
honestly if you just feel like starting
[ __ ] at like a family Barbecue just
stand up and say shark attack shark
attack shark attack yeah
um we have a little TV recap because
love Island was on last night and we
both caught up
and the TV recap segment is brought to
you by Jinx you guys know this Angel
right here is so special and deserves
the best and he kind of has a sensitive
stomach so it's really important uh what
we put into his body so that we can be
taken care of him of course and I don't
like him getting irritated and it's
taken us a long time to get here but
we've gotten here is your dog a wolf a
hard-working Farm dog or a fancy show
dog actually Theo's all three literally
modern dogs do more sleeping and
lounging than hunting and working and so
to keep our pups happy and healthy most
modern kibble falls short on the
nutrition dog needs real quality
ingredients without all the added
fillers so meet Jinx the internet's
fastest growing dog Wellness brand and
your dog's new favorite kibble treats
and dental chews look at Theo's getting
off the clamped their recipes are proven
to support digestion immunity and heart
health so it's designed by dog parents
formulated by pet nutritionists and
approved by veterinarians and it is
loved by dogs this one in particular all
the love you have for your dog is packed
into tasty nutritious kibble every
recipe is crafted with protein super
food ingredients and a patented
probiotic packed together with a
balanced kibble because dogs that eat
better live longer Jinx was designed
with picky eaters in mind it's not your
dog's new if it's not your dog's new
favorite food the Jinx team will make it
right with their 100 money back
guarantee try Jinx and get 40 off with
your first subscription order at
thinkjinx.com toast your dog deserves a
cleaner kibble design for modern dog
hood that they actually want to eat and
you can feel good feeding them your dog
will love it or your money back what are
you waiting for get 40 off at t-h-i-n-k
j i n x.com slash t-o-a-s-t
thinkjinx.com toast thank you for that
Claudia all right love Island I have to
say
on Wednesday night's episode at the very
end when Cinco chose Trina I had a
feeling he was going to but part of me
was like when he was actually saying it
he seemed so sad I'm like oh I think
maybe he's actually gonna pick cash I
was devastated like I really was and
it's very possible that he was meant to
be with Trina and they have like a
better connection but I just don't like
how the whole thing unraveled and when
they were all sitting at that all girls
brunch and basically cash was just
trying to like I don't even know if
that's true like he went for Trina
because she didn't open up she was just
trying to like rationalize what was
going on and I thought Trina was like
being rude like basically saying like
interrupting her and being like I find
that offensive because you're basically
saying like I'm his second choice when
like she really was not saying that at
all and I just I know she was saying it
a little bit well you know what she
should because literally what Trina did
Trina was being a jezebel I don't think
so like this is the name of the game I
think these two girls are friends I
think it's painful for both of them and
you don't need to put one down in order
she didn't even mention Trina no but
like that's what she was doing no she
wasn't and I also feel like I totally
understand my cash is upset but I feel
like
everything that she says kind of is or
is saying like about the situation like
I'm not upset like I think she'll say
like I put up walls with
um Cinco but then she also say like I
was like but then we see her and she's
like him and I'm just like but how do
you really feel because I feel like
she's just like wanting to say the right
things because she knows that like
that's the show like that this you know
you have to be opening everybody gets to
meet everyone but it's like I'm having a
hard time getting at how she really
feels about it that's actually a good
point she does contradict herself a
little bit but I I not for any like
malevolent reason other than I just
think she really is trying to be
rational and not emotional but it's like
you can be emotional it's love Island
love is emotional yeah she definitely is
like has her guard up on on what she
wants to reveal and how she wants to be
perceived because honestly now that he
chose Trina
she doesn't really have any other
prospects she's spoken to no one no but
then Isaiah just popped up and all of a
sudden there's a connection there which
I really like because I like Amy and
Jeremy together me too um I think she
likes him and his bad kissing and all I
know there's just like somebody's so
losery about Jeremy I know I just feel
like whenever we see his conversations
with the woman that he's into like
they're not showing us anything of
Interest substantial yeah but then it's
like he has such a good friendship with
cash and like you see him like around
the house and it's like okay there must
be more to this man because everyone
really likes him and like they all like
respect him and they say he's like the
nicest guy in the house so if he was
such a dud that wouldn't be the case
yeah but he's giving off duty Vibes a
hundred percent and I like Shannon and
Josh once again yes me too honestly I
feel like I'm on the roller coaster with
Shannon like I hate Josh but also like
they're clearly OTP no but also like
when he came back from that date he was
doing the most it was actually the
perfect exercise for him and in being
able to prove to Shannon that he's 100
like he did everything so right like
above and beyond right like leaving
kissing her coming back kissing her like
didn't really give uh Florina any he
said she was like beautiful and stuff
but yeah didn't really give her any hope
yeah my worry with Josh like if I was
Shannon is like on the weeks where the
boys are in charge like he can be a dick
and then on the week where like Shannon
is in charge he's like a kiss ass but
it's actually been the opposite yes
that's true because he I don't think he
realized that the first recoupling was
going to be the girls because he
wouldn't have on that morning kissed Amy
no was it yeah Amy I think you know who
the recoupling is going to be based on
who if there's more boys more boys and
girls I know but it was like the first
week I honestly don't think he knows he
realized wow that would that would
actually be kind of sweet if he didn't
realize because that means he's not just
thinking about sticking around he's just
sort of going with how he feels I just
don't understand why they don't just
commit to each other because then like
when she was like I'm gonna talk to
Isaiah like they get in trouble when
they agree to like be open with other
people but then they get jealous like
why don't you just agree not to be open
because it's too early and they're
really there to meet more people so it's
like if there's going to be someone who
comes in who's better suited for them
then they should they should be able to
discover that because they're there to
meet the person that's best for them I
know but don't they also want to win
and the long couples win so I would just
like find someone who necessarily little
on couples win because if they just cut
became in a couple now and that was it
there was nothing really more from them
they wouldn't win because nobody really
likes either of them yet like they are
not boring they haven't like had to
choose each other over other people like
with Strife it's a lot it's a lot more
than that and still like right now
watching it I don't know
I don't know which couple would is even
a front runner for winning well they're
all so messy like I feel like like
willing Kira but they are boring you're
right and I like don't like them I like
hate them both no I just get I just
think something is gonna happen she's a
lot like and he appears to be into like
her overwhelming kind of smothering
nature
um but that does get old in a house for
weeks yeah and like what if someone
comes in who catches his eye and his
mind like just right now he hasn't been
with met anyone who he likes more than
Cara so that makes it really easy but
like you know who I think he's actually
really well suited for
Amy
they had a little they had something and
they never explored it because he
decided to stay with yeah could come
back around right because like they're
they both speak Spanish they're vegan
they're vegan they're both just kind of
like weirdly intellectual and like uh
you know metaphysical sense yeah he's
always like doing yoga she wants to
preserve the planet for her future
children like I think that actually
they're a perfect match because I think
him and Kira is a very physical
relationship and I think that definitely
will fizzle out like I don't think
they're gonna ride it out together I
don't think it's sustainable yeah it's
too much too soon it's overwhelming like
they are never not together like they
sleep together they wake up they do yoga
together they have breakfast together
they sit on the pool together like it's
a lot yeah just human nature like to be
with the same person for so long yeah so
um
I'm just like loving I know I keep
saying this like being a part of
something even I gotta download the app
and like start voting because like all
three girls going on a date with okay it
didn't make sense because because they
all said who they wanted they came in in
the first episode and we when did people
vote because we were watching the
episode when we met them and then later
no at the end of we got to introduced to
them and then they said it said go vote
at the end of like an episode from the
end of last week okay but I really like
Corey and Florina me too of course I
think that actually if they can like
like that's a couple where it's like
okay we see what they have in common
they've explored other people they're
really and if they got together and then
continue to build like that's a couple
that could win yeah no I think they're a
good couple too and of course I was
happy for Corey because he's like had
literally nothing going on nothing
um but all three girls getting the date
like made no sense and it wasn't even a
date it was literally them sitting in
the corner of the house I thought they
were gonna leave no it was really silly
but then they got their actual dates
which sucks for Corey because they were
like I'm not taking Corey on a romantic
day because we've already spent time
with him and so they took people that
they just wanted to talk to that they
hadn't gotten against you guys yeah the
house is so nice like thick every time
they pan I'm like I would love to go on
vacation here like it's so bright and
colorful the slide looks very dangerous
and every all the houses like they do a
really good job with the neon signs and
like the bright colors the big heart
also the females like just looks and
Glam and outfits are just so on point
you want to know why because I think
like I think they spend most of their
day it's like sitting in that makeup
room because they really don't swim that
much or like do anything they like work
out in the morning and then they like
gossip and they always gossip in the
room so if that was me I'd be sitting in
the air conditioning flat ironing my
hair the entire day no it really is like
Camp I think in the morning they do the
workouts and I do think they that they
swim but they probably can't wear their
mice while they're swimming so there's
nothing that interesting and then I
think it's like shower hour and then
they all like that shower they all step
out and they do their like slow-mo and
like they walk to they each get a glass
of wine and it's just like must be the
most fun camp I agree as well but let's
talk about shower hour do the boys and
girls have separate showers
because it always looks like they're in
the same room not at the same time I
think that they do because it's CBS and
the house is huge yeah why would there
be one bathroom but they probably just
look like are the same exact layout
because I always see them like in the
same shower as the boys but then it's
also multiple heads in the shower
there's no doors right so they're just
you know so looking at each other
something that happened a few weeks ago
like no actually like maybe at the
beginning of this week when Cinco was
like starting to have feelings for Trina
again he was talking to the guys and
they were in the shower and he was not
in the shower and he opened the door and
stuck his head in to talk to them there
was two guys in the shower so he was
like looking at two penises being like
uh I don't know what to do like cash is
like you know I'm having second thoughts
or whatever and I'm like did you just
stick your head into the shower yes he
did and if I had to guess I would say
would be because maybe he thought the
audio wouldn't get picked up oh oh yeah
and they do not let go of those
microphones they sleep with them like I
know oh and I never I didn't really
understand why every time they wake up
they put on sunglasses it's because
they're under production lighting when
they've just been asleep yeah and the
room gets so bright from being pitch
black yeah awful yeah I think the only
thing I couldn't envision myself being a
part of is the sleeping Arrangements
like of course being in a bathing suits
yeah but having to sleep with a stranger
and not only that in a room with 15
other people it's actually very
unsettling like what if you fart like
you know what I mean yeah I'm sure
there's a lot of farting yeah like I
haven't slept with a stranger since I
was like in college we'll camp
yeah I guess but like
in Camp you're only with girls and like
you're all just like yeah farting and
like you're shaving your legs like
you're like yeah all like gross together
but like with boys like you wouldn't do
that yeah that's the part that like also
I felt that way about too hot to handle
and the two hot to handle beds are very
small I think they're full-size
mattresses where I think is in love
Island they're all queen size yeah no it
seems like pretty like a good setup and
I'm sure they got Comfort like maybe at
first it's weird but I think they're
like comfortable now I'm sure when they
go home they like Miss all their
campgrounds that's how I used to feel I
can't like it missed you know the
loudness the camaraderie of the bunk and
then you get back to your home and it's
like so silent so quiet I think it's a
child I went through like many a mini
depression after camp like I took it
really hard I think most that's a sign
of a good summer 100 now I crave the
winters
um and that is outward show that is our
show so for next week let's talk about
it I have lined up a couple guests a
couple premium guests I'm really excited
to watch the schedule is not set yet so
I will be posting at some point over the
weekend the entire schedule for next
week I'm really hoping to do Monday
Tuesday Wednesday in studio with
fabulous co-hosts and then you and I can
catch up Thursday Friday with some
podcast only Trends Atlantic Continental
trans Continental content so um stay
tuned I will keep you abreast but I'm
just working on some last minute
Logistics I've got two out of three of
the co-hosts booked looking to host one
more but I'll keep you abreast as always
but we'll be in studio on Monday so just
stay with us yeah I'm so excited to
watch I'm excited for my trip I'm gonna
miss you guys but I'm really excited I'm
excited to get away you know I always
come back with so with the whole new
energy
ways to tell and I really I think that I
need that you know it's like this in
this heat of July and like it's time for
me to go
and it's time for us to go into our
weekends and for you to go back to work
or to start drinking I don't know thank
you guys so much for listening to the
morning shows the millennial Morning
Show where we deliver the past five
stories that you yes you need to know
before you wake up Monday through Friday
before you wake up and take a bite no
before you this is what the problem is
right thank you so much for listening to
the morning toast the millennial Morning
Show where we deliver the past five
stories every Monday through Friday on
YouTube so if you're watching this on
YouTube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as a podcast anywhere
podcasting we found so on Spotify iTunes
Stitcher public radio I read a castbox
all the places so every listen to
podcast find us when you shall leave a
five-star review about our beautiful
stunning and smart we are now that we
know that a lot of people still listen
because all of you guys left the matcha
Emoji today I think shark Emoji today oh
for sure shark emoji on our Instagram
this is like a secret little Society I'm
so excited thank you I can't believe how
many people commenting right now it was
so fun to watch love you guys we have to
wrap it up so people don't think there's
something happening love you guys have a
great day we'll see you on Monday bye